[Applause]
what do you think what yeah I'm helping
my neighbor's kid get started as a
tailor so I think he's got potential so
big news in my family grandma is online
now and we are learning a lot about her
political leanings we knew she had a lot
of interest in quilts and the the
conspiracy stuff was a surprise
everything she types is all caps well
that's the first thing they come for it
the government is your lowercase letters
she's having trouble keeping up with her
password so she created a little text
file containing the passwords she saved
it right on her computer desktop she
went ahead and named the file all the
passwords your move WikiLeaks
we may finally get to see that
blackberry cobbler recipe she's been
keeping the secret for years she doesn't
do the online shopping again something
to do with the government I like it it's
a time saver right but they try to claw
that time back a couple days after you
buy here come the emails hey this is
Josh could we get you to rate that
purchase could we get some packaging
feedback on there would you like to
write an online review of your recent
purchase yeah that's what I want to do
take an unpaid internship in your
marketing department yeah no no it's
great I don't have to go to the mall
anymore but I have to stay by the phone
in case I need to talk Josh off the
ledge right buddy you're killing it with
the packaging where's this negativity
coming from the pattern envelope it was
inspired you're just being silly I think
he could pretty much buy anything online
now my wife recently bought this little
handheld electronic thing that grinds
the dead skin off you heels seems like
you should need a permit or some medical
training before you take a power tool to
your foot right
she loves it well it's got diamond
crystals on it diamond honey if you need
the same abrasive they use to drill
through the Earth's crust to find
petroleum may be time to bring in a
podiatrist on this day if it's that hard
that may not be skin anymore you may be
into the bone
we should probably pump the brakes so do
you remember when we thought the
internet was gonna be this wonderful
tool of research and knowledge I saw one
of the dummer fights on social media
recently this one guy posted a thing
about Bitcoin the digital currency and
the guy in the comments was just
hammered him telling him he was crazy
and wrong but about halfway through you
start to realize he's not talking about
Bitcoin he's talking about Coinstar
machine at the grocery store that counts
for change yeah I don't I'm not familiar
with the rules of classical debate but
I'm pretty sure you're all supposed to
talk about the same thing a little
farther down the thread there's a
comment in all caps
oh boy grandma's here
he's talking about her Fitbit oh we're
not getting anywhere
the technologies changed so much just in
my lifetime when I was in school I was
still typing my term papers up trying to
get to the minimum number of pages the
night before it's due taking longer and
longer quotations from my sources this
was helpful it's not exactly on point
but I think the Gettysburg Address would
fit nicely now the kids these kids today
they can just cut and paste if they want
to plagiarize I had to literally cut the
page out of my library work
paste it on the blank typing paper
finally just hand the book to the
professor what he said I've never heard
it express so beautifully is right here
enjoy you just wanted to stop but maybe
the technology will save us all they say
soon we won't have traffic anymore we're
going to that beautiful automated
driverless car mmm that sounds relaxing
sit back in the passenger seat with a
good book and let whoever's hacked your
system to drive you right in there dead
it's so cool down here even if you're
not hacked you got to trust that
computer that'll be fun careening down
the freeway at 110 in the wrong
direction on the phone with tech support
so you're saying I should just turn it
off and turn it back on again okay
really funny
Oh
you